hello everybody John Perry here welcome
back to what's it Wednesday this is last
week's guest and as many of you figured
out this is a bald eagle congratulations
to pretty much everybody because pretty
much everybody figure that out YouTube
user Peter Carey osya I think I'm saying
that right he requested that I make them
harder because this was too easy for him
so alright I'll do it I'll give you a
harder one now keep in mind you're not
supposed to be googling this stuff
you're supposed to just use your eyes
and your brain to figure out what these
animals are but this week's creature is
this fascinating little guy what could
that be
might pull in a little more light this
little creature I mean you can see his
head or her head I don't know fits
easily in my hand very small little
critter but he has got some teeth on him
look at that huge canines let's open up
the mouth so you can see what on earth
could this thing be no googling gotta
just use your eyes in your brain what on
earth could this critter be something
really neat I want to show you about
this guy is how big the olfactory bulb
is its brain is kind of split into two
sections there's this front section here
and the back section here
fairly large brain for animals is small
but if you look inside here
maybe if I bring a light there we go if
I bring the light in front of it you can
see you see that spongy bone in there
that spongy little bone there is called
the ethmoid bone that bone is where the
nerves from the olfactory bulb poke
through into the nose so that you know
that's the the smell region at the part
of the brain that smells well I guess
interprets smells and the olfactory bulb
in humans is tiny it's like I don't know
like two little earth worms sized things
but for this guy the ethmoid bone is
huge and there's a whole separate
chamber in the skull to house the
olfactory bulb the part of the brain
that you know sense of smell this thing
depends heavily heavily on smell
in order to make a living and probably
to socialize and do other things so it's
just fascinating I mean you know we we
can't even imagine really what it's like
to experience the world mostly through
smell like this animal does really cool
trait this is in my skull collection
this guy's probably got more of his
brain dedicated to smell than any of the
other animals that I have look at that
in there so so cool and it's almost like
that the brain is sectioned off so
there's the normal brain and there's the
smelling brain in front really cool
those are his upper teeth
here are his lower teeth if they will
focus focus here we go
it's just beautiful so there you have it
what's it Wednesday episode three can't
wait to see what you think this is